[Music]
absolutely monstrous performance what
you see in valorem right now is what cs
is going through as well literally every
event is online and it seems like every
week they're just different results and
pure in a 1v2 situation to try and hang
on to get us to ot to secure the spot in
berlin they just can't do it 100 thieves
how's your german because you're headed
to berlin i'm going to berlin
i've never been here that's good i think
aston is probably
still to this day for me one of the most
interesting players you think of like
the rope play on the ice box like how
many times we see him do things it's
just like that's cheese he shouldn't be
able to do that but it's acid us so he
gets away with it now knows what's
coming his way he's going to put up
anything he can to try and make this
trickier so then close the gap asana
great breakthrough kill but good work
again astro is still doing it but see
then he's here he's finally arriving he
gets set back in nitro out of nowhere
asana is putting in serious work right
now
peter asana mazurik is a special breed
of player his hyper-aggressive
highlights have taken the valerant world
by storm and have helped turn him into
one of the game's most promising young
talents but like most of the game's
early adopters asuna got his start in
esports with counter-strike he's good
enough to bring the crack back still
asuna with that og gets one gets two but
asana never quite managed to make it to
the big leagues so when the valorem beta
came out in april 2020 he left
counter-strike to focus on riot's newest
title he signed with immortals later
that summer they found me by uh word of
mouth the four that they already had on
the team hyped me up a lot they said i
was insane and ranked and like i had
really good i was very good in cs so
then i tried out as breach i played
really badly and they i didn't message
me back for like a week and then
eventually they decided to try me out on
raise and i played insane and they
picked me up and it didn't take long for
austin to show the world why immortals
gave him a chance he's going to come up
through a short sending out gary gary
give him what he needs maybe it's going
to be the grenade that actually locked
down that kill enough to not get it on
the walls out the walls out it just
leaves venerated by himself and they
actually have he go on the other side
and they get the kills immortals i
cannot believe it immortals have been
able to lock this thing up and they're
moving on to the next round his
performances throughout the summer of
2020 helped catch the eye of 100 thieves
who at the time were in the middle of
rebuilding their roster so they messaged
me on twitter i um just responded back
to hiko saying yeah i'm free to try out
i tried out we like remember the first
crim or second screen we played was
against tsm i mean like those two maps
we took a map off them actually so like
i was almost positive we would join
after that scrim because like csm at
that time was like really good 100
thieves new roster was stacked with
veterans who were happy to help foster
asuna's budding talent their trust in
his abilities allowed him to fully
showcase his trademarked aggressive
style
is the triple off the rocket is the
fourth kill he's working on the ac
that's an absolutely monstrous
performance there on short a looking for
the last player and from the very start
100 thieves established themselves as
one of north america's best teams gsm
there's only two players left there's a
two versus four for tsm they have to
find a way out of this situation but
it's getting worse and worse and who
better than hiko to look to seal the
deal here in this grand finals as carlos
tries he does all that he can but it's
simply not enough against a hundred
thieves a hundred thieves they've done
it they are your first strike north
america champions
heading into 2021 riot announced the
next step the valorem champions tour the
game's first official tournament circuit
gave teams a chance to qualify for
valorent's first international
competition in reykjavik iceland and 100
thieves seemed destined to represent n a
but as the season got underway
things didn't go as planned he's gonna
have to win three fights to keep his
team in this it's not gonna be easy
he'll take one and the second he needs
but one more lockdown's gone now so it's
just victor with two curveballs and six
ap on nitro the peak won't work victor
takes it and that's an easy defusal mb
will take the series and they keep their
chances alive in the finals after being
knocked out of the stage two challengers
finals asana and his team were forced to
watch from the sidelines as sentinels
and version one represented north
america at the game's first
international event but while 100
thieves waited for their next chance at
an international land asana continued to
make his presence known to the valorant
community
thousands of viewers tuned in to watch
him stream his daily domination of the n
a ranked server all while giving them a
window into the real asana bear nice
bear
criminal activity
on stream asuna is a ranked demon he
pulls off places that most players could
only dream of while his mom makes sure
to keep him well fed and when he's not
busy sharing his anime obsession his
aggressive style makes him nearly
impossible to play against
he's kind of like a psychopath where
he'll just like do something and like
you know he's gonna do it but like even
knowing he'll just still kill you
overall just as a player just bring down
the bare bones just kind of fundamental
attack fps mechanics there's very few
people i feel like who actually
rival asana in terms of his positioning
his aim his reaction time he's just an
amazing player when the qualifiers for
masters three got underway asana brought
his ranked energy to his pro matches the
immediate pop of the empress needs to be
done for a sooner now because he knows
he's gonna be potentially going up
against both players he's right to
assume that but it doesn't even matter
and icebox in particular became his
playground
goodness
ethan's also there's more down low
austin wants to get aggressive just on
the ropes one in the seal team six is
this he's gonna find one the right click
he's gonna confirm the ace what in the
heavens is that asana's performances
throughout the stage three challengers
playoffs helped 100 thieves qualify for
their first international event in
berlin as na's second seed and pure
the 1v2 situation to try and hang on to
get us to ot to secure the spot in
berlin they just can't do it with a 2-0
victory 100 thieves how's your german
because you're headed to berlin
i've never been here
this is what hunter thieves was made for
despite austin's youth the team was
built to play offline nitro heco and
ethan had plenty of years of land
experience and they knew what it took to
compete on the world stage this is a
really big kill but no austin who comes
away victorious yes the spike is down
but again they're pinched in they've got
nowhere to go and awesome is doing
things like that
cleaned up austin are good for three the
empress comes online nitro gets the last
hundred thieves get to seven now liazi's
dropped as well 100 thieves looking to
put the finishing blow on this thing
they wanted hit him hard that's exactly
what they've done now hiko's gonna use
his hunters fury not getting anything
going quite yet but still does as it's
just down to crane the guardian no magic
happened a 13-6 win on the second map
hundred thieves they start off berlin in
beautiful fashion shade off's good for
wine we go eco trades wind
24 health running for
chronicle
has plenty of health chronicle on the
tap
he's gotta get rose don't fake he's
gotta get it to happen
he gets the red bull clutch 100 thieves
were down but they steal the round away
from gambit to push us to map three
maybe not map one or first half of map
two but they are living up to the hype
now and they're picking up right where
they left off the break doesn't seem to
cost much of a difference at all it's
awesome is able to get second make that
three and dashes away they get a spot
down to steal no steel swings out
definitely's not able to land a shot
steal does it nitro does it as well they
were down but they refused to go quietly
into that good night they take down
gambit they're going to the knockout
stage 100 thieves miraculous comeback
versus gambit helped them top their
group and secure a spot in the
quarterfinals and the north american
squad wasn't finished yet seen it take
some damage and asana closes it down no
harm no foul the map is one there was
nothing weird nothing no out of ornery
happened there after splitting the first
two maps against ascend 100 thieves fell
apart on breeze the turkish superstar
cened was dominating the game and they
couldn't find a way to stop him steal
your last man alive
ain't gonna happen cena shuts the
chapter on this round in a sense time to
tear away with a bit of a lead but then
being down 12-7 with their tournament
lives on the line 100 thieves decided to
change things up killers now knows
what's coming his way he's going to put
up anything he can to try and make this
trickier so then close the gap asana
great breakthrough kill but good work
again astor is still doing it but ceded
he's here he's finally arriving he gets
set packing nitro out of nowhere and
zeke can only take steps the gun barrel
shows he knows it they live to fight one
more round they continue in this fashion
but asana is putting in serious work
right now their strategy was simple
identify where cena was then run away
and it actually worked he's closed the
gap ethan's coming with another this
could be it a hundred thieves on the
verge of destroying ascend
ripping the lead away from them as zeke
and c ned need to rise above and they
can't do it nitro to close a flawless
round to win it on and again beyond
against the round score against every
aspect of this game a hundred thieves
just rose to the occasion asuna and his
team managed to win seven straight
rounds in a row pulling off one of the
greatest comebacks in ballarat history
they proved that having a team of
experienced land veterans is sometimes
more valuable than raw mechanical skill
probably after the round we talked about
that's that's when 100 thieves almost
knew they'd pulled it off like that that
was the one where it's like okay we've
sort of broken them now when you break a
young team like that it's it's so
difficult to get your head back in the
game whereas with 100 i mean you could
there must be like 35 plus years
combined of like veteran land experience
there um on that roster which is it's
worth its weight in gold in in that
scenario alone but after their third
place finish in berlin 100 thieves was
about to make a tough decision
[Music]
100 thieves benched steal and brought on
boy as a substitute for the last chance
qualifier and with only two weeks to
prepare for the most important event of
the season nobody really knew what to
expect from 100 thieves you know maybe
it's just like we haven't had enough
time with this roster and the role
switches that we've had
with her in game weeding and the actual
agent swaps to actually figure out you
know it doesn't come natural at this
point right we've had what almost six
months to eight months with ethan and
without making your roster change so now
a lot of things have changed a lot of
our calls and our strategies have
changed so i think we just have to like
grind it out and get used to
some of these situations that we
normally would you know have an answer
for they managed to take down gen g and
even x set in the opening rounds but a
loss to rise put them on the brink of
elimination and in the lower bracket
final their dreams of making it to
champions were shattered stepper kids
they're second guessing their angles
it's not working as boy comes up with a
big frag it's up to him the newest
member of the team can he keep the
series alive boy staying in the oh he
gets hit by zeppa that's gonna be the
defuse there's more than enough time
cloud nine lock in grand finals they'll
face raise to get revenge things went
from bad to worse in the offseason as
nitro announced that he would be
returning to cs and still officially
left to join t1 one of valeran's most
promising rosters was all but gone
[Music]
but there was one constant heading into
2022 austin's presence on twitch he's
still grinding ranked on stream almost
every day
wait i did not understand how i got the
second kill his willingness to improve
and learn while dumpstering some of na's
best has allowed him to become one of
the faces of valerian on the entire
platform
okay i think he has an incredible grind
mentality i mean as you can see like
he's he has two accounts in the top ten
and he's just absolutely cracked and
demonic but like he's a type of person
that doesn't like make excuses doesn't
get complacent i think aston is probably
still to this day for me one of the most
interesting players uh you're thinking
like the rope play on ice box like how
many times we see him do things it's
just like that's cheese he shouldn't be
able to do that but it's acid us so he
gets away with it ahead of the 2022 vct
season 100 thieves have added eccles and
baby j to their roster but no matter how
many changes 100 thieves makes one thing
is for certain asana will continue to be
an absolute menace in the server he
might only be 18 years old but he has
already proved that when his team needs
him the most
he'll come up with something special
[Applause]
let's go baby
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our twitter instagram
facebook and tick tock